what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some news about the
X-Men 97 animated series that is going
to be coming to Disney plus today we
have our very first official plot
details for the upcoming series as well
as the series details about what Marvel
studios's plans are for the series such
as how many seasons is this series
actually going to be a lot of fans are
really excited about this series because
they watched the original animated
series and now it looks like this is
essentially going to be the same thing
as X-Men 97 is basically going to pick
up where the last X-Men animated series
left off and if you are a fan of the
original X-Men animated series it looks
like they're going to be sticking pretty
true to that original format with X-Men
97 so this is going to be a real treat
for us who watched the Animated Series
so we have plot details like I mentioned
including who the villain is going to be
and how exactly he comes into play in
the new X-Men teams la lives so recently
Marvel had the X-Men 60 uncanny years
live virtual event where the X-Men 97
showrunner Beau demaio gave fans a lot
of details about the upcoming project
including the plot and the beginning of
the X-Men 97 animated show and it sounds
awesome he starts off by stating okay
we're gonna be picking up about several
months after Professor X left Earth
after being shot by Henry guyrich and
had to return to the share Homeworld to
be with Alandra and what ends up
happening is that assassination attempt
has led to this wave of increased
sympathy towards mutants and
understanding which has always basically
been the X-Men dream and the dream of
Professor Xavier that's always been the
dream however demaio does state that the
X-Men weren't expecting this so he
continues to say and things are despite
the Friends of Humanity still having
their mullets and getting all up in it
things are really starting to look up
for mutants and this this is gonna kind
of come to a head and leads our X-Men to
say what does our future hold for us we
weren't expecting this and you're gonna
have Cyclops and storm really wanting to
carry on the dream and they've recruited
morph and Bishop to actually become
full-time members of the team he even
goes on to reveal that even Magneto is
going to have a change of heart he
continues to state that other X-Men like
Jean and Gambit and Rogue are starting
to begin to question well maybe there is
a life we've been fighting for this life
of acceptance can we just go out there
and enjoy it for once maybe and then of
course somebody shows up who shouldn't
show up and it's Magneto who's also kind
of feeling like you know Professor X he
did a solid for mutant kind I'm going to
try to walk in his footsteps I'm going
to try to be a force of good for mutant
kind and real quick I just gotta say
that I truly do love this one thing that
I've always loved is the relationship
between Magneto and Professor X I've
always loved the different variations of
the stories that they've had together
and I actually think that one of the
best X-Men scenes that we've ever gotten
was when Professor Xavier died in X-Men
the Last Stand and right before he dies
Magneto yells out his name Charles
out
I love that scene because in that moment
they have been fighting each other for
years at that point and even though they
were technically fighting each other
right then and there even in that moment
Magneto reaches out and yells for
concern for his friend because he does
not want him to die and he goes on in
that movie to say that Charles Xavier
did more for mutant kind than anybody
and is one of the greatest man ever and
I love it so I love that they're going
to be exploring this with Magneto and
even though Magneto seems to be a little
bit conflicted he does want to honor
Professor X and demaio continues to say
but then of course as the X-Men are kind
of looking at the future and we're going
to be talking a lot about this how do
you face the future how do the X-Men do
what they've been telling Humanity to do
for decades witches embrace the future
now all of this sounds fantastic this
sounds like it's going to be a really
great storyline for the X-Men of course
though one thing is missing people are
asking well where's the conflict who's
the villain going to be if humanity is
now on the side of the the X-Men and
they're being sympathetic towards them
and they're actually getting along and
even Magneto himself is no longer a
villain well what exactly and where
exactly is the conflict of the show well
of course don't worry they did go on to
reveal the villain a very Sinister
villain demaio States a very very very
very very
favorite character of mine and many
others Mr Sinister will rear his ugly
head from the past with a pretty
foolproof plan to destroy the X-Men once
and for all now I like this because I
believe there are a lot of different
components that could come into play
during this series for one they have
already confirmed that Magneto is indeed
going to be the leader of the new X-Men
team yes storm and cyclops are going to
play a pretty big role but Magneto is
actually going to be the new leader
trying to do right by his old pal
Professor Xavier and trying to basically
honor what he did for mutant kind but I
also really like the fact that Mr
Sinister is going to be the villain and
that he is going to become coming from
the past because his pretty foolproof
plan might not actually take into
account the fact that humankind is now
kind of on the side of mutant kind Mr
Sinister might not know this about the
current time that the X-Men are in and
this could definitely foil his plans
which are seemingly bulletproof but at
the same time when he comes from the
past to the future he may not have known
that and this may disrupt his plan
because that might have actually been a
part of his plan humankind being against
the X-Men so he might get a pretty
shocking surprise when he comes to the
Future to destroy the X-Men finding out
that one not only is Humanity on their
side but Magneto is on their side as
well one of the most powerful mutants
ever and let's be honest I think we all
expect at one point in time Professor X
to return whether that's the final
episode or the final episode of the
first season whatever it may be I think
a lot of us are expecting his return and
speaking of Seasons Insider Casey Walsh
did reveal some information about what
to expect as far as the series is
concerned turned and how long it's going
to last and apparently Marvel has some
pretty big multi-season plans for X-Men
97 as I mentioned Insider Casey Walsh
has revealed that Disney Plus's X-Men 97
is being planned as a Four Season effort
from Marvel Studios he says it's
expected to go four seasons and should
come out in Fall 2023 so we don't have
an actual release date so this maybe
gives us a little bit of clarity on when
to possibly expect it but the great news
is is it does seem that Marvel Studios
has multi-season plans for X-Men 97
which is fantastic because I'm really
looking forward to the series and I know
a lot of other people are as well and it
sounds like it's going to be pretty dang
good so far we have some really great
X-Men appearing in the show Magneto is
on the X-Men side leading the X-Men and
humankind is now on the side of mutant
kind as well and then of course we have
a pretty great villain coming in Mr
Sinister so go ahead and let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below are you excited for the anime
series X-Men 97 coming to Disney plus
hopefully this year if there are no
delays please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe if you want to stay
up to date on all things happening in
the MCU and of course with Marvel
including X-Men 97 you can also follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
okay
baby videos